indudablemente uno de los temas
primordiales de esta campaña al menos
para los lulistas ha sido la lucha por
el medio ambiente lulista se que
denuncian como también lo denuncian las
cifras una altísima deforestación del
Amazonas desde el 2019 el dato nos dice
que han sido aproximadamente 34.000
kilómetros cuadrados de Selva que han
desaparecido y como bien alerta la ONU
las temperaturas podrían aumentar para
final de siglo en el planeta hasta 2,6
hay grados Celsius en ese sentido las
Naciones Unidas han advertido que una
lucha para evitar que aumente más el
cambio climático es la misma lucha para
proteger el Amazonas en ese sentido se
han pronunciado Los Seguidores de Lula
que aspiran a una victoria para este
domingo y con Juan Gabriel No possonara
fue una catástrofe acá Así el gobierno
de bolsonaro fue una catástrofe acá
porque bolsonaro destruyó deforestone
desde su inicio hasta acá sí que
deforestó mucha amazonía no tenemos más
tiempo para bolsonar bolsonaro sería la
destrucción del planeta
Pero sería la destrozó de planetas
siendo el Amazonas uno de los pulmones
de la tierra por no decir que el más
importante saben los electores de Lula
que este debe apalancarse en los que
saben y precisamente ahí ha sido clave
en esta campaña la figura de Marina
Silva de Reyes y sustentabilidad allí
que siempre ha trabajado los temas de
medio ambiente en este país y con ella
La idea es que Lula va a denunciar los
planes que vendrían para renovar la
protección sobre la amazonía de ganar
este domingo
vamos a tener que unir a la sociedad en
torno al proyecto de Lula que es un
proyecto de recuperación de los
organismos y de fiscalización Esa es la
primera cosa no intentar retomar los
organismos que hacen la fiscalización de
la amazonía que ellos están
completamente desmovilizados Lula tiene
la propuesta de crear un ministerio
votado por los pueblos originarios
existe una buena expectativa de mejorar
la situación bueno Y finalmente pues es
Claro que no fue un tema de campaña para
bolsonar el medio ambiente de hecho
tampoco lo fue durante su gobierno por
el contrario ellos buscaron la
explotación del Amazonas para beneficiar
a los madereros y para beneficiar la
agricultura también aumentaron de manera
astronómica a los incendios ilegales en
la amazonía Y aunque los datos a veces
pueden variar se cree que el daño Es del
tamaño de Bélgica